des pionniers black blanc beur dans les
années 80 à la finale régionale bboy
france la danse hip hop a fait du chemin
et a toujours sa place à traces
l'association ouest est agent de
maurepas en charge du championnat s'est
associé à la nourrice pour accueillir
l'événement il ya trois catégories qui
vont se disputer la 7e cette fin d'après
midi
voilà il faut savoir que toute la
sélection tout l'après midi on avait une
soixantaine de danseurs qui se sont
affrontés pour finalement non voilà on
en retenir
on va dire que un seul par catégorie
dans la catégorie pop rock où les
danseurs sont debout deux trappistes ont
défendu les couleurs de l'association
très hip hop
tous deux se sont qualifiés pour la
finale régionale foulani va affronter
les grands le terme utilisé dans le
milieu pour désigner son professeur
savoir que chez attrape à la maison dans
mon quartier avec une grand qui m'a tout
à fait c'est une grande émotion pour moi
je préfére d'elle ben j'espère que va
postuler est toujours aussi discipliné
dans son travail assidu dans la finesse
le regard et surtout l'accomplissement
de soi la petite a finalement surpassé
son grand c'est elle qui représentera
l'île de france de la catégorie top rock
le 10 novembre à liévin dans le pas de
calais